say what you want about Dragon Ball fans
but animation quality surely wouldn't be
something that tops their priority lists
right yeah
through the years Dragon Balls animation
has been questionable at times but of
late the animation teams have been
caught on more than one occasion with
their proverbial pants is down often
producing work I would aggressively
criticize a young child for it's no
wonder toys animation studio made
worldwide news wait a certain not naming
names episode aired sue with magnifying
glasses at the ready let's take a look
at the work of a young animation team
struggling with an impossible workload
pull the rug from beneath their feet and
laugh at them as they're falling I'm
totally not Marc and these are the 10
worst animated moments of Dragon Ball
super bottle of God's Ark number 10
Vegeta's silly face the cheetah doesn't
normally have a silly face usually void
of silliness in fact with the skulls so
unyielding you would think it was
tattooed onto his face at birth at the
end of the now infamous fifth episode
the cheetah appears to be judging by his
face incredibly angry at this lounger
for whatever reason he can be stretchy
his armpits for liner that's a thing
that bodybuilders do right but hey I'm
not one to judge this guy's got muscles
in places I don't even have places look
at this man it's insane Oh God after a
brief Conville wink I the cheetah sits
up and this is his face oh Jesus ah
number nine the grill Inspira see we
don't see much of curling these days
once a prevalent character throughout
Dragonball Z in the mid-90s times have
not been good to the old crow dog join
up less and less in this series it feels
like he wait he's shorter why is he
shorter like he's way shorter maybe this
is the beginning so many but surely
Crillon will shrink out of existence and
then and then it's Marans time or maybe
TOI doesn't like doing things on model
but that's ridiculous
hahahaha oh god number eight Gohan fails
but looks happy Goods character is
taking an interesting turn in recent
times no longer trying to follow in his
father's footsteps anything interesting
at all for that matter it was equally if
not more exciting than the Great's a man
has reared its ugly deformed boy ridden
head Gohan is
a salaryman no longer training or
keeping a strength up to say his
character is slip slightly is like
saying it there was a slightly mean man
in his first big moment of the series
thus far
Gohan channels his ultimate form lashing
to defend his friends from lord beerus
who is having a physical altercation
with the reason my friends gave up on
Dragonball Z what's worse
beerus doesn't even touch Gohan instead
throws the pink abomination with force
at him
go in is knocked for a loop by the
bubblegum man looks way too happy about
it almost like he's laughing at her
groceries God is number 7 Gohan
stupid face is stupid all avoid the girl
had trained cuz here we go again with
another Gohan entry I'm starting to see
a pattern here are you Kelly can't seem
to draw the old fan favorites faces in
the other position the neutral these
days so Gohan has become the Switzerland
of Dragonball this scene is important
and at the very least should be touching
it's the announcement of going infidels
first born half Saiyan pan and plays a
crucial part in the continuation of this
arc this is the face he made isn't it
Jesse jorb it's creepy it's freakin
creepy
number 6 hands okay okay
hear me out I'm calling - breaking the
rules here with this one and this isn't
exactly a dragon ball super isolated
moment per se but these not hands hands
have infected this whole list pick an
episode and look at these things for
yourself look at those things hanging at
the end of their arms you'll see maybe
I'm being a little overly critical here
but when I watch the episode that
distracts the hell out of me but hey
maybe that's just me and I have some
weird latent hand fetish I was unaware
of either way toey animation needs a
hand God do I write this number 5 Goku's
Fathead
I love Goku he's my favorite character
always has been it's not a popular
decision but you know what bring on the
hate I say I'll just be sitting here
watching patita struggling to the Goku
shows up to secure the victory my
unrequited love for Goku aside I was
thoroughly entertained watching this
fight between goku and lord beerus hit
what no no no not you I'll get to you
you know what you did
but in this battle there were a few
moments that had some interesting
choices in animation to say the least
permit me if you will to set the scene
beerus got a destruction the most
imposing force in the known universe is
toying with our hero with the Earth's
fate in the balance goku must master and
channel as much energy as he can in this
newly acquired super saiyan god form
sounds good right well guess what if not
this this what is this okay I can kinda
see what they were going for with a sort
of fisheye camera angle thing but it
just looks so incredibly jarring it took
me out of what was and still is a very
good fight if not just for a moment
number four goku vs beerus screaming
contest okay I'm calling all my classic
Dragon Ball Z fans here for this one you
know who you are the grizzled vets of
the cartoon network toonami days the
dark days when patience was your only
Ally to combat the episodes of screaming
powering up and posturing and waiting
for Goku to get out of that goddamn tack
excuse me what I'm trying to say is
we've been through the toughest of times
and in truth Dragon Ball super is much
more forgiving than the original Dragon
Ball series ever was and that was
obviously intentional with the release
of things like Dragon Ball Z Kai however
this episode was in my opinion really
bad the lead animator proving to the
world that he doesn't believe in bones
and that all creatures are made of some
weird rubbery material he looks to his
wife and asks what the boom she
immediately starts crying and pours
herself another glass of wine in this
Clash of the Titans Goku embarrass Punch
hands they scream and then they repeat
and when I say repeat I mean they repeat
these faces as in they make these exact
faces with these exact frames multiple
times in this episode now I understand
that this is like a common technique
used in the animation industry in order
to cut down on cost but I don't think I
was supposed to be laughing when I saw
these faces somehow my opinion it
couldn't have hurt to redraw some scenes
number three the Cheetahs rage against
beerus alright now i realized this could
be an unpopular opinion with some but
hear me out this doesn't look nearly as
bad as the others not by any stretch of
the imagination but it promised so so
much more and could have been vegeta
shining moment in the series
this is the very first time beerus to
destroy is put on the back foot and
taken by surprise by the individual
strength the cheetah is one of the most
if not the most popular characters of
all time in Dragonball this is his first
big moment and if I'm being honest the
animation fell flat for me jittery
lacking in flow and I gotta say hokey
but the part that bothered me the most
was that Galaga and fired towards the
end of the confrontation what was
supposed to be the climax to the
greatest effort we have seen in the
series thus far turned out to be at
least for me hugely disappointing more
disappointing that anything I had seen
in the series up until this point at
least from an animation perspective a
blast that once looked like it was
capable of enveloping the entire world
had been reduced to two straight lines
lazily thrown together with some pink it
had no substance and a promising scene
ended with a disappointing whimper an
energy blast with no energy in the
drawing number two the Cheetahs two left
hands people don't normally have two
left hands and if you were to draw one
with such I would scream at you for an
unreasonable amount of time good thing
TOI doesn't think that way because if
they did this might not have happened
you are indeed looking at the cheetah
with two left hands a professional
animator working for a professional
animation studio drew this let that sink
in
number one Goku vs beers King Kai's
planet are we ready to begin no sir we
are not ready to begin because my client
is not arrived here she comes to Ric
bidet history sorry your honor ah this
seed this glorious beautiful scene it's
brought so much joy to my life said no
one ever and this travesty of trash goes
on for the entire fight sequence in
making this video I have come to know
that toy does do stationary well but as
soon as they move this happens even
having two left hands is more convenient
and who are the conductor's for this
sin-free of disaster you may ask well
thanks to the fine people over archives
n chew you can take a look yourself I'll
leave a link in the description down
below
Towey animation has since released
blu-ray copies of this arc with the
animation fixed now it looks like it's a
- how about that but after all that said
and done I have to say I'm actually glad
it happened
some of the best Dragonball videos in
years were made making fun of the
subject or fixing it it's really
remarkable what some talented youtubers
and harness can do to turn a bad
situation around and that's my own this
guys do you agree disagree or do you
want to tell me how I'm wrong about
God's gift to mankind the greatest
character in the world Goku let me know
in the comments down below I'd love to
know what you think if you want to see
more or less like this one be sure to
subscribe for more I'm totally not Marc
and this is being the 10 worst animated
moments the Dragon Ball super battle of
gods arc thank you so much for watching